so I guess my mom I found a lot of like
old news oh my god thing it's
unbelievable
of me and it sent them all to Bobby yeah
and and I want to say this right now
okay I knew verbally she told me that
you know I used to be kind of a big
thing in the Philippines as a swimmer
and you kind of imagine I go okay I
guess you know cuz I had some news I was
in newspaper ones as a wrestler my
brother was a couple times you know as a
wrestler and um but hers was a legit I
mean I saw nine articles just on a whim
she just sent it to me but 90% of them
she's crying in them
but because she lost it I mean she's
sitting there like you know me she took
the second place and they keep a photo
of her as a kid crying because you know
that her mom you know Miss Hannigan he's
gonna rip her off [ __ ] new [ __ ] and
you could see the pain and suffering
that she went through as a kid so that
picture right there what was your media
thought there's a couple others of me
crying mmm I am I think that I didn't
take losing very well when I was younger
because a lot was riding on my shoulders
it wasn't a sport that I could just
enjoy for you know because you know as
sports should be it should be enjoyable
but at that age you know I was you know
we got money from the Philippine
government if we want certain things if
we broke certain work records if we swam
for internationally and at that time my
parents financially weren't doing very
well and that's another one is another
that's what the papers yeah let's choose
the one the one I love shines in u.s.
Junior swim fest and then a picture of
an old picture me crying it makes no
sense yeah sighs a lot rode on more than
just winning so I and I used to get beat
you know so it was like it isn't perfect
I know even parents are really rough the
worst there's no there's not a moment to
like chill and relax like it was all
work and all
grit and all hard work it's [ __ ]
awful I don't really want to remember it
and maybe a lot of it has to do with
your heart condition maybe even do you
think yeah I think I I warm my body to
the ground too early you know I've been
doing I'd been doing two-a-days since I
was eight years old which is like way
too young but at that time like they
didn't know any better so they're just
like yeah just make him workhorses and I
used to have these like traps like I
swear to God I was ten years old I had
the biggest traps in the world I look
like a little dude just cuz that's like
that's all I did I woke up at 5:00 in
the morning swam went straight to school
at 7:00 7:00 to 4:00 p.m. I'd go to
school then to the weight room then back
to the water come home at 9:30 p.m. do
homework start all over again
oh my god I mentioned that I'm a [ __ ]
I'm the opposite in competition I
remember a time in um when I was 12 I
did a martial arts tournaments we used
that to spar right yeah it's a fight
people
yeah this guy I usually don't do on it
because I hyperventilate yeah it's not
real
yeah so I'm Sarah now I was a liar as a
child yeah I for some reason one or by
default made it to the championship
round had to fight a girl named Jackie
Elaine from Alabama top competitor I was
so scared that after she hit me the
first time yeah wait wait ed it's a girl
it's they used to mix it at 12 years old
they used to be boys to a girl who's
just get ready for go what happened was
I got hit yeah man point that's you know
they got flag stuff it's like the karate
tournaments and then I did not want to
feel embarrassed anymore losing to her
or just fighting in general yeah so what
I started doing is when I they say fine
I go like you can't breathe I can't
breathe and I just fake collapse yeah
and I remember everyone like surrounding
me to stop it I look at the quarter my
it's my mom my mom goes oh she knows I
do this all the time on Saturdays during
was boring rehearsal so what'd you do
oh they just stopped the whole thing she
won you're a [ __ ] so you pull out you
just don't know stop stop
that's the [ __ ] saddest thing I've
ever heard
yeah I know that's what you did I had to
survive that's you shouldn't fear of
embarrassment I first I didn't like
getting hit yeah I'm like getting hit
this girl was very dangerous let me see
your this twelve-year-old girl whose
piece is very dangerous
Christian base martial arts academy and
they would pray only laughing you get
punched by Jackie O Lloyd George can you
find a photo over now or photo yeah I'm
so ashamed
maybe we should get a different [ __ ]
guy